before hypest before I was a month or
two old my father had announced to the
world that that I would either be a
doctor and go to Cambridge or a
philosopher and go to Harvard so
apparently my father knew something
today that I didn't I only discovered
this later on looking through press
cuttings I didn't I don't remember this
from my childhood and as it happens I
did study medicine at Cambridge and I
did teach philosophy at Harvard so sort
of interesting I mean I don't remember
the first time I realized that I was
really interested philosophy I think two
things happened one is I happened to go
to a school where there were other
people of my age 15 16 17 who got
interested in they were they were
interesting and smart people and I hung
out with them and we read philosophy
together partly influenced by a couple
of teachers one one a chaplain and the
other an atheist it's hard to believe
this especially if you read language
truth and logic but I found a book
called language truth and logic in the
book room at our school the place where
you could buy books and and I found it
extremely exciting and this was a sort
of positivist manifesto I'm not any kind
of positivist really but it was but the
idea that you could think rigorously
about these important questions and that
you could sort of break break through
the sort of encrusted assumptions of
your society or or of societies in
general and sort of see through to to a
clearer vision of what the world was
really like and what was really
important and so on that struck me I
think it's very exciting and I was going
through a religious crisis at the time I
was I was evangelical 15 16 year old and
I was and I suppose I was in the process
of losing my faith though I wouldn't
have known that at the time but I was
very interested in sort of theological
questions and again the kind of rigor
with which philosophical argument could
address these questions which were
addressed I thought less interestingly
perhaps by
the sort of Sunday school or a religious
setting I think that was part of what
excited me I have to say that while
that's what sort of brought me to the
subject I don't find myself terribly
interested now in in those questions in
the United States where the vast
majority of people claim some sort of
religious belief haven't thought much
about what that means I mean they
haven't thought about what it means not
in terms of what they should do but in
terms of how they should think and in
particular people are very vague I think
about what they mean when they say that
they think there's a God and one of the
things that I found helpful in
philosophy as a 16 16 17 year old was 10
spy philosophers to say but most of whom
were quite devout and religious but but
they were nevertheless people who wanted
to be more sort of rigorous about what
that meant than most people I'm using
this word rigour and I don't I mean I
Aristotle said you should adopt the
level of precision that's appropriate to
the subject so and he was right
basically philosophical research has
done by reading and writing and talking
to people and I would say that you know
the what philosophers try to do is to
get clear as we can about the conceptual
issues that surround some of the more
important questions that human beings
have to deal with like if is the regard
and what what is he or she like what how
should one come to make moral judgments
what is it for for judgment to be true
but also what is it what does it mean to
say that there are quirks I mean you
know science generates new questions all
the time what's a species that these
questions have theoretical is there a
theoretical issues in physics and
biology but there also raise
philosophical questions and which
philosophers
tribute to helping to understand so
there's a vast range of things you might
be spending your time on and I think the
distinctive contribution to philosophers
is to try and be more careful about the
conceptual end of these questions then
most other people have to be it's not
that other people should be doing what
we do we should be doing what we do they
should be getting on with what they do
as well but it's useful into the
civilization to the culture to have
people around who do what we do I like
to tell students that you know in a lot
of life if you want to figure out what
to do you can make a sort of three step
argument that three step argument for a
philosopher is going to be broken down
into thirty steps we're going to look
between the first and a second step
we're going to find ten ten stages and
we're going to argue that it makes a
difference how you understand each you
tutor or it can make a difference how
you understand each term and that this
is why I think philosophers since
Socrates who was who was mocked for this
by our Stephanies that the comic
playwright have been regarded as sort of
you know logic choppers and and kind of
fussy word mongers and you can do that
and you can get kind of fetish about
making distinctions which have no point
and I'm not interested in that most
great scientists when they say things
about the philosophy of science about
how one discovers scientific truth about
how one justifies scientific claims
about what distinguishes science from
non science and nonsense but most but
most scientists say about that is I
think
not terribly interesting it's not
philosophically rewarding a lot of it
you don't have to have a good
theoretical account of the nature of
your activity in order to pursue that
activity at the highest level and that
applies just as much to physics as it
does to ice skating great ice skaters
aren't people have a great theory of ice
skating and great physicists aren't I
think people have a great theory of
physics that people have good at
figuring physical things out doing doing
the experiments or doing the theory the
mathematical theory that's required but
they don't necessarily have a better
grip than other people on on what it is
about what they're doing that's
distinctively successful just as one can
be one can have very good vision but not
know that it's photons of light
banging onto your retina that's giving
you the messages so you can be very good
at figuring out scientific things I'm
not very good at understanding how the
sounds work so um ah so I don't think
that the task of philosophy of science
say is to provide scientists with a
theoretical account of what they're
doing that's going to make what they're
doing better they're doing fine by
themselves if that's the question and we
don't need our help in that but science
is a source of thoughts beliefs
propositions which the rest of us
whether we're scientists or not have to
figure out how to fit into our world and
that's I think a place at which
philosophy can be useful I think
philosophy belongs in the humanities
because I think the humanities are about
they're about transmitting what's
valuable in our civilization for
everybody if all the physicist has to do
is get the physics right it doesn't
matter whether we understand her it
doesn't matter whether she's rich you
choose a public intellectual or not all
that matters that's her task I think
some philosophers do things that perhaps
are very hard to mediate to a general
public but if the whole business of
philosophy isn't connected with the
general life of the civilization I think
it's lost its point a large part of what
we're trying to do is to provide a
framework within which we can think
about all
the other things we do not from as it
were on top of them I'm not saying
philosophy is as they used to say the
queen of the science isn't they say that
about theology actually but but I'm
saying rather that philosophy has this
this special place because we try to
think one philosopher once said
something like what how how how things
in general fit together in general or
something like that I mean I think that
that is a distinctive role so you know
I'm happy to work at the theoretical end
of many disciplines I've done work
saying literary theory which i think is
sort of useful for the study of
literature but and so it's sort of on
offer
to literary theorists students of
literature if they're interested but I
don't think they need to do that in
order to be good at what they do it's
just that sometimes we can come along
and notice and notice one of those
famous distinctions and it can help to
clarify an issue in another field you
know people borrow from philosophers all
the time I often they borrow in ways
that philosophers find a bit puzzling
because they they seem to involve
borrowing things without really
understanding them in the way that a
philosopher would count as understanding
them but that's okay I don't mind that
either but I think that I don't want to
claim that as where everybody's
profession would be better done if they
spent 10 minutes a day doing the
philosophy of the profession I don't
think that's that's true I think I think
it's rather than what we think about is
the relationship between what
everybody's doing and what everybody
else is doing and how each of us can
sort of fit it in together in a picture
of the world and in constructing our
projects and deciding how we're going to
spend our life